-Our next guest
has his comedy special,
"Rage Against the Routine,"
available on YouTube.
Making his late-night debut
here on "The Tonight Show,"
please welcome the very funny
Mike Feeney!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Thank you so much, everybody.
Wow.
I appreciate that.
Exciting news --
I just celebrated seven years
of marriage with my wife.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, yeah.
We've been married seven years.
We'd been dating
a total of 17 years, though.
Yeah, I know.
I had to make sure.
And --
[ Laughter ]
If I'm being honest, she's one
of my favorite people right now.
But when you're
in a relationship that long,
a lot of times, after shows,
from men, they'll come up to me
and they'll be like, "17 years."
I mean, my God,
I must have gotten so stale
in the bedroom by now, right?
And every time,
I have to explain to them, like,
"No, it hasn't gotten stale.
It's gotten efficient."
That's how I would --
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Like, our sex life is like
going to a Billy Joel concert
at this point.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
We're just playing the hits,
no new stuff, everybody's happy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
You're never gonna go
to a Billy Joel concert,
and he's gonna be like,
"This is off my new --"
Like, "Buh buh buh! 'Piano Man,'
get to it right now.
Hurry."
[ Laughter ]
"You know why we're here,
you know?"
[ Laughter ]
My wife and I,
we got a dog recently,
which was such a great decision.
'Cause we always had cats,
and I would defend cats.
Any time someone
talked bad about cats, I'm like,
"That's 'cause
you never had one."
Once you get one, you realize
they got their own personality.
They're cute, they're cuddly.
They're the best, you know?
And then we got this dog,
and I looked at the cats,
and I'm like,
"I have never loved you.
This relationship is over."
Like, I just --
[ Laughter ]
Because the doggy is adorable.
He's, like, a 40-pound
lab-beagle mix.
He's got the big dumb ears,
always looks like he's smiling.
I love this little guy.
But nobody told me
the social contract
that comes with having a dog.
Very different from having cats.
I used to walk around
New York City.
People don't really talk to you.
Then you get a dog,
everybody wants to talk to you.
But not about you,
about the dog.
So, you have to learn
every single thing about them
because dog lovers
are crazy people.
Did you know that?
[ Laughter ]
Dog lovers will just run up
to you with questions
that need answers right now.
They're so aggressive.
And for my dog,
it's always the same three.
They always go, "Oh, my God!
What's his name?
What kind of dog is it?
Is that as big
as he's gonna get? Oh!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Is that as big as he's gonna --
I'm gonna keep feeding him,
if that's what you're asking.
What?
Yeah, he'll probably get
horizontally bigger
for the rest of his life.
And then, God forbid,
you see another
dog owner with their dog.
Now it's
a mandatory conversation.
The second we see each other
down the block,
we have to start communicating
being like...
[ Laughing ]
"Yeah, yeah.
He's fr-- Can they say hi?
Okay!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Don't let the leashes
get tangled.
Okay."
[ Laughter ]
And every dog owner will tell
you that their dog is friendly,
and almost none of them
are friendly.
[ Laughter ]
You don't even need
to look at the dog.
The owner is like,
"No, he's good."
Like, they're getting yanked...
[ Laughter ]
...down the block while
the dog charges me like...
[ Imitating dog barking ]
Just full speed.
And then stay start shouting
very specific commands at you.
They're like,
"Let him get your scent,
but don't look at him
in the eye!"
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "why?
What does that mean?
What'll happen?!"
You know?
"What's your dog's name?
Medusa? Oh, my God!"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
I travel a lot for comedy.
I have to fly often.
I get very nervous
flying because -- fft! --
you know, that possibility.
[ Laughter ]
So, I drink on every flight
that I'm on.
I don't care.
If it's 6:00 a.m.,
if it's 10:00 p.m.,
it's sky time.
You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
The second that door locks,
I'm like, "I'll do a keg stand.
Do we have one?"
[ Laughter ]
I was flying across the country.
It was an early flight,
and the woman came up to me.
I was like, "Hi. Can I
please have a vodka soda?"
And the first thing she did
was she looked at her watch.
I was like, "You can check
that judgment at the door.
Okay?"
[ Laughter ]
"Put that baggage
in the overhead compartment."
You know?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. No way.
Like, "You high-altitude hussy.
I will not be judged..."
[ Laughter ]
"...by somebody who wears
a paper hat, you know?
Like..."
I didn't say that.
I'm a coward.
I tried to make it easy for her.
So, I was like, "Oh, I'm gonna
have more than one drink.
Could I please open a tab?"
Which I thought was a very
normal sentence to say.
And this was her reaction.
She goes, "Sir, this is
an airplane, not a bar."
[ Laughter ]
I'm not exaggerating
her shoulder.
She literally went,
"not a bar," like that.
She shimmied her shoulders
at me?
It made me furious.
I was like, "Oh, I'm sorry.
I must've got confused
when you pushed
a mobile bar up to my seat..."
[ Laughter ]
"...Frisbee'd a napkin at me..."
"...and said, 'What'll it be?'"
You know?
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "You're a bartender."
You know?
"You're a bartender in the sky.
You're a sky tender.
Call it whatever you want,
but --"
So, I got very petty.
I was gonna have two drinks
on the flight.
Instead, I had six.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah.
And she did not
let me open the tab,
so I had to run my card
six times.
And on the sixth time,
she came by with that
little credit-card machine,
and she was like, "Um, sir?
I just want to let you know
there is, like,
a gratuity option on here.
So, you know, in case
you want to leave a tip,"
and then handed it to me,
which made me so angry,
I had to return my seat to the
upright and locked position
and just looked her
right in the face,
I was like, "Oh, I'm sorry.
This is an airplane,
not a bar, so...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you very much.
I'm Mike Feeney.
♪♪
-That is how you do it, buddy!
Fantastic, buddy.
That is how you do it
right there!
Mike Feeney!
"Rage Against the Routine"
is available on YouTube.
We'll be right back, everybody.